looking to be go
off the wing skating with it now
terrific overnight they score and
they've tied the game up
Eagles wrist shot was heavy and quick a
lot of times the goaltender feels like
his positioning is perfect and he's got
the net cover guess what
he doesn't
the puck is Gupta by Pavelski store
uncle on the powerplay
loose puck did not go very well there
one driver
and gathered in by Emily a shot not a
reaction say
are in the 60th minute out of 60 fires
store
puck loose denied by the defense nicely
off that wall
these toys Jonathan days
on side
what do we have here Oh penalty shop
well the defective player was trying to
go for the puck on this breakaway
opportunity but clearly does not get the
puck gets all skates we got ourselves a
penalty shot
the Kings with a games greatest event a
penalty shot
yeah shooters love to beat the
goaltender
the glove side don't they handle the
butterfly position covers the bottom of
the net doesn't help a much here though
one-timer didn't miss by much
and he holds on this game has really
started heating up and it's carried over
to after whistles
whoa and it's over with one big punch
how did you score that one dead even doc
those are the type of fights that you
really enjoy